if you prefer to snack the pain away
well we've got the perfect breakup treat
for you and food news
i like this the food
reports that you can heal a broken heart
by smashing your dessert some of these
breakable cookies and cake come with a
mini hammer for some deep cake catharsis
now we've got breakable chocolate hearts
from chalk it up right here in new york
gail what do you think of this
i like you know how you were just
talking about naming an insect and
giving it to a snake
it's sonic i would like to name the
woman
who i caught in my home with my husband
who i thought was a friend so i'm going
to do this in her honor
okay i love this ready one two three
[Applause]
there really is stuff in here
[Applause]
by the way there's chocolate in this one
and jake
where are you
hello how are you hi
hello no you're both single
yeah
do you guys know each other
we just met you just met oh where is
this going drew um i did notice you guys
conversing quite a bit has anything been
discussed other than the show at large
well most mostly just the microphones
um
we seem to have some similarities in
what we do in our jobs may ask what's
your favorite food ooh
you want to go first
uh
some
baja fish tacos
fish tacos okay
uh i'm a real i really love especially
to cook um bread pudding
oh
i didn't see that one coming me neither
bread pudding i like how you asked her
to go first i thought that was i noticed
yes since you're both so sweet um we
wanted to give you and the rest of our
audience a little treat nyx ice cream
created these valentine's day bundles
inspired by iconic rom-coms that's right
and i know a thing or two about
they have 50 first tastes
that's really cute um and then um guess
what you're all getting a 150 gift card
for nick's ice cream and keto snacks
which is awesome
but
there's no one on planet earth that i
would rather feed ex-boyfriend insects
to snakes and smash heart cakes and
talk about love okay happy birthday
[Music]
you